people are starting to join so we can
get started with the introduction
so um hello everyone it's my uh pleasure
to
to uh welcome you all to this week's
edition of the synthesis workshop
at the simons institute um i'm really
delighted to introduce today's speaker
professor jerry zhu
from the university of uh wisconsin
madison
jerry is a full professor in the
department of computer science at the
university of wisconsin
and his work is broadly in the field of
machine learning he has worked on
multiple aspects of machine learning and
in particularly has made
landmark contributions to several topics
including
especially in machine learning theory
jerry has received many honors and
awards
including particularly an icml classic
paper prize
now let me say a few words about uh the
tutorial here that jerry is giving today
right so so jerry is someone from the
field of machine learning
and our simon's program and this
this workshop series is broadly speaking
in the field of formal methods
and programming systems and related
areas
and um i think jerry is actually even
though he's not
in the field of formal methods and
programming systems
um he is particularly well suited to
give this tutorial
in recent years jerry's research has
been on topics like machine teaching
and adversarial machine learning which
as many of you will see
has direct relations to topics like
program synthesis
and formal verification also
i had the the pleasure of uh
co-organizing a dark school seminar
about four years ago with jerry on the
topic of machine learning and formal
methods which is
one of the first such meetings as we saw
the
two fields coming together and i think
we have seen uh especially in synthesis
a growing
interest and use of machine learning um
so i think jerry is really well suited
because although we've seen a lot of use
of machine learning and synthesis
i think the use of machine learning
theory
to develop the theory of synthesis is
still
at its nascent stages and i hope this
tutorial can serve as a kind of a
catalyst
to to to bring new ideas into the
into the synthesis area so with that
uh jerry uh thank you for giving this
tutorial and i'll turn it over to you
thank you so much for the kind
introduction sanjit
um as sanjit mentioned i'm really an
outsider uh so what i want plan to do
today
is to go over some of the sort of inner
works of
machine learning and to try to build a
bridge
in in trying to do in trying to do so um
i acknowledge that i don't speak your
language
so i would extremely welcome people to
interrupt
and ask questions clarification uh or
make comments at any moment
and sanjit please do help me in that
regard
okay thank you so much so let's get
started
so today uh depending on you know how
how fast i can go i plan to go over a
bunch of things
so the talk is roughly speaking split
into two parts
the beginning of the talk is uh things
we already know in
machine learning that has been you know
well developed for a while
this is essentially the notion of
passive learning or path learning you
heard of it all the time or statistical
learning
learning from so-called id data
i'll explain all these things now the
theory is extremely well developed
but on the other hand it is also
limiting in that the learning agent
interact with the environment in a very
specific way
and this may not cover a lot of the
interaction protocols
that we might be uh interested in
informal methods
so after that i'm going to branch out
and uh you know
start to look at some of the more uh you
know interesting
branches of machine learning so we will
start with active learning i will talk a
little bit about
the notion of teaching which is the flip
side of learning
then we will look um spend some time on
a so-called sequential decision making
so online learning
multi-on bandits and reinforcement
learning all right as i was saying
earlier the hope is
uh these are going to be just core
machine learning concepts
and my talk will not have examples in
synthesis or formal methods but i hope
this provides a brief outline
so that we see what is available
at a very high level in the machine
learning field from a theoretical
perspective
and what we can borrow to bear in
our study of formal methods so with that
let me start with
the basic setting of passive learning
uh this is like the most important slide
uh
i want to make sure that we are all on
the same page to establish this
terminology
uh we will be looking at uh for now
let's think of very simple
classification problem okay so that's
we will start with uh so i'm going to
use the notion of
x for an input space and
that just means you know the item that
you give to the system
all right so this could be for now let's
say natural numbers
1 2 3 etc now that's going to be capital
x
capital y is going to be our output
space or label space
so for example in the simplest case
binary classification we have 0
one label so if you give me a number
like 10
i'm going to somehow predict whether
it's zero or
one class okay so binary or we can think
of it as negative or positive
okay um with that
i'm going to start introducing the
notion of essentially a classifier but
now let's formally call it a hypothesis
uh because it's hypothesis let's use
h so h is a function it's a function
from the x space mapping to y
in this talk i'm going to frequently use
an example which is this little h i
being the indicator function of x
greater than or equal to i
so you know if you have for example x x1
sorry
h1 that's just going to classify
every natural number as one okay
uh x h2 will be a classifier that
classifies
one the number one as zero class
but uh two and three and uh beyond as
the positive class so as
ones so i'm going to sometimes use the
alternative notation h i with this like
this string of labels
and they just denote like where the
negative class
ends and where the positive class starts
uh so in the natural number order right
so h
i literally that i is the ice position
is where the
the positive class the one class starts
okay so these are the uh the
hypothesis that we will be looking at
and
on top of that uh we will have a
hypothesis
space capital h um
this is in general uh a subset and
in fact we should have a true subset of
uh
all possible such functions so for
example
my capital h could just be these little
his
uh so it it is a threshold function
right so it's a family of threshold
functions
with different threshold location i okay
so it's an infinite class
but it's very simple it doesn't include
any other functions
that you know map say odd numbers to one
even numbers to zero
we're not including those uh in my
example here but in general
that's my hypothesis space okay
and finally i'm going to say that
there's a target
function this is denoted as h star
that is something we want to learn okay
so this is the hidden function and the
world is going to generate
data for us according to this h star and
here we distinguish two cases
one is when each star is in my
hypothesis space
so for example my space of threshold
classifiers and in this case we call the
thing
uh realizable so the setting is uh known
as realizable for example
we could say each star is that
particular
threshold function age 2021
uh so that's going to be a function that
classifies all you know first
2020 numbers natural numbers as zero
and then starting from 2021 it's going
to classify everything as
one afterwards okay so that's that's
that
now of course you could also have a
situation where uh the true target
function h star is
not in your function family not in your
hypothesis space
so here's a concrete example h star is
this
function that's all once except at the
second position it is a zero okay so
that is not
representable by my hypothesis space
okay we will consider both cases
and the in this case is called agnostic
or
unrealizable all right so i want to
pause a little bit because this is like
the
most important slide to anchor our uh
you know the translation between machine
learning and uh
formal methods in particular synthesis
so
one question actually i have a question
right for
for for you guys um i think this is uh
uh quite related to how one could think
of uh program synthesis
where the hypothesis space seem to be
all the programs that we can synthesize
from say a given grammar
and h star would be the the correct
program it's specified in some ways
right and
it seems like uh x and y would be the
input and output behavior of my program
if you query if you give the program an
x
it should output y for example uh is
this a valid
uh interpretation center maybe
sure i think that is a valid uh
uh analogy uh one point of difference
though is that uh in in program
synthesis
uh uh typically you you don't have a
specific target
you don't have this specific target you
have a specification that defines a set
of
correct hypotheses right and so
uh and as long as you get everything in
that set you're fine
that is actually a very interesting
point
um right so there there could be um the
notion that you truly have two different
h star functions that really have
different uh you know
um uh they they map x to different y's
uh in that case yes we will have a
family of h stars and that's not
a setting considered in machine learning
we typically say there is just
one h star a concrete function okay but
we will see
later on that uh this notion may show up
again
very soon all right
so um so let's talk about how we think
of
passive learning but a little bit from a
theoretical perspective
it's not just like we hey we collect
training data we we train something
right
so the way we formalize this is to say
learning happens between the environment
which essentially holds everything i
just discussed in particular that
uh that letter h star and
um and the learner so the environment
uh in standard passive learning is
described
by not each star itself
but a joint distribution p over the xy
space
okay so it's a joint distribution so for
example i'm just making a very concrete
example here
um let's assume that px here x is our
natural numbers uh is this geometric
distribution
uh by some parameter lambda so the way
we think of it is like hey this
puts more probability on the natural
number one and less probability on two
and so on so forth decays but it puts
something that's normalized over
all natural numbers and we can define
the joint by you know the product of p x
and the condition of p y given x
so in this case let me define that p y
given x
to be a very sharp distribution so it is
given x it puts uh it has a it's a
distribution number y is right so zero
or one
it puts all probability mass on the
correct
label so that's the indicator of you
know y equals
h star x so this is a very nice
situation we have an underlying
distribution that's
sharp but x is somehow not uniform it's
decay
okay in reality for most machine
learning problems
the py given x part is not going to be
this sharp
it's going to be for multi-class
problems it is
going to be a multinomial distribution
that's not concentrated
so we will have label noise we will come
back to that
all right so but assuming i have some
joint uh
pxy representing the environment
then what happens is we assume it's the
environment
who draws a training set and i'm going
to call that trending set
uh capital s the trendy set is just n
i d samples strong from the joint pxy
okay uh so let's let's think what this
might
uh mean right so let's let's look at the
following example so let's say
we have the threshold uh hypothesis
space
and uh h star is this h 2021
all right so it's realizable we actually
have it let's say
n the trending set size the size of s is
modest it's not like millions but think
of it like maybe hundreds
okay so um
because our px is specially designed
it's like geometrically decaying
we should expect that uh quite often our
s
does not contain in the beginning of
natural numbers
okay so just for the sake of argument
let's say in your whole training set of
you know n
items the maximum value of x that we
have everything is 100.
okay now that means because of uh our py
given x definition
it's a clear label right so all our
labels are going to be zero because
the the maximum x did not pass the
threshold 2021.
okay so you get a training set of size
and everything is negatively labeled
okay and that's it that's the training
that you are supposed to work with
as a learner right so the learner now
receives
this training set as now the learner
has that hypothesis space capital h
and it must select some h-hat
and that's the learned model from the
hypothesis space
now what's the principle of doing it
right so
the thing i want to emphasize is you
know this trend is that s
is in one sense maybe okay but
in another sense quite weird because it
really doesn't tell you where this
threshold
starts you have no information that
uh the the threshold is at 2021 because
you don't see any positive example
so for all we know given this training
set with all negative labels
the learner could very well pick a chat
to be just
h101 which you know put the threshold at
the 101 because then it will
classify everything in the training set
correctly
but you might say that well this is not
good because um
h101 is far far away from h2021
okay that you're correct if what we're
measuring is
uh the notion of hey somehow uh where
the the distance between thresholds okay
but on the other hand this is a tall
order
this is not what machine learning can do
for us
in fact machine learning is aiming for a
much lower bar
okay it is only looking for something
that has
small risk so let's let's look at that
and that's why machine learning is
solvable so what are we care
care about right what do we care about
um to define that
let me first introduce the notion of a
loss function so this loss function
l is a function over a pair of labels y
and y prime
the most commonly used loss in learning
theory is the so-called zero one loss
that's
very simple it just counts it just looks
uh if y equals y prime or not
if they differ you incur a loss of one
otherwise you incur a loss of zero
okay now with that we can define
what machine learning truly cares about
it cares about
the risk or the true risk and this risk
is called r
r of a hypothesis h it is defined to be
an expectation over p that means we draw
x y pairs from p and the way you think
of it is like this is a test item xy is
a test item
it's draw from p again just like the
training items
and with x y you apply your little h
to it to make hx is your predicted label
you compare it against
the label why you generate it and you
apply that loss function so if it's zero
one loss it's just like saying hey
did your little h classify x correctly
as the given label y
okay uh if not you incur uh
one here and then you take the
expectation that's just the probability
of your little age making a mistake okay
so um so that's the risk we care about
now how this risk
uh relates to uh to you know
it ties the joint distribution pxy that
the environment has
to that h star uh technically h star is
going to be
the argument of all possible hypotheses
now this includes things
in or outside of your specific
hypothesis space
okay so it has all this um
hypothesis it goes over them and find a
minimizer okay
of that risk so h star is really the
risk minimizer unfortunately this is
potentially outside of your model family
okay so that's the agnostic case
right so for realizable case we have the
assurance that each star is indeed
inside our model family okay now the
learner's goal
of course is to eventually try to
minimize
our age or hopefully try to do that but
um it really cannot do that
because it doesn't see the underlying
distribution p
it only sees a monte carlo sample right
so a trending set
of size n drawn from p so that that's
the fundamental
difficulty of machine learning okay
but i also want to say that because our
goal
is now test as minimizing risk
so if i'm the learner i learn some
little h hat
i would be happy if r of little h hat is
small
okay but i i don't necessarily aim for
h little little h hat equals h star
that was what i mentioned previously
okay
furthermore uh we all know in machine
learning we have like hey you should
train but then you should evaluate on a
separate
test set right so a test set error is
nothing but a multi-color estimate of
the
risk r because a test set is nothing but
another id sample drawn from p okay
so that's how it relates so from here on
we will be
thinking of this true risk now
that's of course behind the scene in a
way because this true risk involves
expectation under p
which is inaccessible to the learner so
the learner having only earnings set as
what it can realistically compute is
something called
empirical risk or this is nothing but
trending set error when you have zero
one loss
this is denoted as our hat so
in this part of the tutorial this hat
notion is quite important and uh
it's flying everywhere so i want to make
sure people are happy with it
are without hat is such risk r with a
hat
is with respect to the empirical
distribution of s right so that's just
summing over your training set
what's the loss so as we can see this r
hat
is again a monte carlo estimate of r
okay so that's the setup so far
now now we can finally come to like how
should we do machine learning
right in theoretical machine learning
the way you do
learning is very simple you do it by
something called empirical risk
minimization
this is not the only way by the way but
this is the basic way to analyze
algorithms
what is it it's literally just
uh the middle equation here's what the
learner is doing it's called erm
it is trying to find a little age
within the family of hypothesis
available to the learner such as our
linear threshold
hypothesis family and uh
it's trying to simply minimize the
empirical risk
okay so just literally minimizing
training set hour
okay now whenever we have argument
recall argument really is a set right so
it's the set of hypothesis
in your hypothesis family that will
minimize
our hand in in general that set
uh may contain multiple hypotheses so in
fact in our example
when you have a training set as
uh whose largest item is 100
while the true threshold is 2021
we will have a whole bunch of
hypotheses in that argument set h101h102
etc etc these are all
valid empirical risk minimizers
and we do not specify how the learner
would choose one out of them so
the assumption is the learner is just
going to arbitrarily choose
any one of them that's it it costs
learning down right so it chooses
a member in the argument set okay
uh let's see so maybe i should just
pause quickly and see if there are any
questions or comments
i don't see any questions in the q a or
chat
okay great um please do post something
if uh
anything becomes unclear all right so
now you might object to what i'm doing
here because this screams like
overfitting right so i'm really
minimizing trending set error
and isn't that just the best thing we're
taught to do to
not to do in machine learning 101 and
you would be right in some sense
but um we will see so what is
overfitting
uh so unfortunately overfitting is
actually not a technical term
it can mean a whole bunch of things uh
the the most
usual sense is are the true risk
of h-hat what your learner learned
through erm
is much greater than our head which is
the training set error
of your classifier okay
so that's the most usual sense it's like
hey i trained my
model it looks great on my training set
but when i
apply it on the test set it suddenly has
a huge error right so that's the first
sentence
but you could also use overfitting to
mean
several different things like the second
one is
the true risk of what your model is
is much bigger than what could
you ever get the best thing you could
get h star
okay if that's much bigger that's
another sense of
overfitting the third sentence is well
you cannot
literally compare to the each star the
best possible one uh maybe it's
uh the best one how about the best one
in your model family that's accessible
to you
okay so it could be that your hat is uh
is not so good
um even though it's good on training set
the true risk is much higher
than what you could have chosen as the
best threshold and this is already
showing up right we
we sort of see that if we choose h101
that has a zero training set error but
it will have some
true error and it is not as good as the
infimum here which would be
age 2021. okay
so what machine learning wants to do
is to carefully quantify
these differences and one way to do that
is to uh you know let's conceptually
think
how we should describe that rh hat the
error
of something that you trend on you
obtain from
training the true risk of that and the
way you
decompose it is you can just literally
introduce and cancel out
terms to break it down into three parts
so these are known as uh estimation
error approximation error and
base error now uh you don't have to
stare at the formula let's look at that
example
um so let's uh take our hypothesis space
to be
again natural numbers threshold function
okay threshold can be at any place
but let's take h star to be outside my
family right so
it puts a zero at the second location
but otherwise it's all zero
okay now with that let's start from the
base error part
the base error is introduced when
the environment has a conditional
distribution p y given x
that is not concentrated that just means
it's not a one hot factory it doesn't
with probability one
gives you the correct label it may have
say an epsilon
uh corruption so whenever you have x
with some probability epsilon it will
actually show you the opposite label
okay but with one minus epsilon it's
still going to give you the correct
label
so this is what uh is known as like in
the in the
base optimum classifier sense you should
still be able to recover
h star but now you incur on the
training set orange test set you will
incur that epsilon noise
that is not avoidable because the world
is just putting some
noise there okay so this is unavoidable
it's known as base error it's kind of
like the floor
okay so that's that on top of that the
second component
is known as approximation error you can
literally think of this as
you know this is a model error of your
hypothesis family or hypothesis space
capital h
our capital h is all threshold
classifiers
so it literally does not include h star
okay and that's
um that's the that's the nature of the
error so we're simply looking at
the error incurred by
the closest family uh closest member h
prime
in your family and in this case if our
px is geometrically decreasing
you can show that h1 would be the
closest member in your hypothesis family
to that h star okay because
that's the zero there you can you can
verify like h2 which
would be like zero one blah blah it will
make two mistakes and still it has
higher error and so on so forth
okay so this part of the error
is due to as we were saying miss
specification of your hypothesis family
okay we will come back to this but uh
short answer is this is not something
machine learning theory has focused on
people pretty much viewed this as a
modeling issue and
you know kind of like an engineering
hand engineering issue
that one need to construct that capital
h
carefully the third source of
error is estimation error and this comes
from the fact
that you don't see it on the line p but
you just see a
sample s of size n draw id from that p
okay uh so there's s by itself is a
random variable
uh so you should expect to see you know
a variety of training sets in our
example
uh let's say occasionally
it's plausible that your ass training
set
may contain uh you know the second item
x equals two and it's correct
label zero there uh and it may contain
x equals three and so on but let's say
it does not contain x equals one
okay so your learner would not know the
label of x equals one
okay given that training set if you work
out the erm
it's going to actually pick h3
as the minimum risk classifier drm
okay um why well because it doesn't
have a representative training set it
doesn't know that
uh x1 should be classified as one
okay so that is the error
that is um if you look at it
look at the top line on the screen the
estimation area is really defined as
comparing with the best in the family
but in terms of the true
risk right so we know h3 in fact will
have a higher risk
than h1 h1 is the closest in family
okay so this is something that we can
handle this is something that as
intuitively
you can avoid if you increase your
training set size
then you will likely see x equals once
in your training set and you will not
pick
x h3 you will pick h1 instead okay
so this is the error decomposition
and uh in fact
uh classic machine learning theory only
concerns about estimation error it does
not concern about
base error or approximation error it
just says how should i
try to reduce my estimation error okay
and this is coming up
and this is the famous uh probably
approximately correct guarantee or pack
guarantee uh for the sake of uh
simplicity
i'm going to assume that uh for now that
our hypothesis family is
finite now that's not in my example my
example has
that being all threshold functions over
natural numbers
but let's for example assume i truncated
so my
hypothesis family stops at some large
threshold okay assume that
now the theorem itself is stated in the
following way
it says um the probability
over s over training sets is going to be
large enough
or greater than one minus delta so that
just says
very likely you will get a training set
as
with the property stated inside the
bracket
okay um that really is just like saying
hey you will not
receive a very strange training set okay
so what is the property the property is
if you perform erm
on that training set you get a little
age cat you look at its
true risk which you don't know but we
guarantee you
the true risk r of h hat
is not too far away from what you
were the best member in your family
okay so the infimum over the best
threshold function that you could have
chosen
if you knew the whole uh are sorry the
whole p
distribution um that
is bounded and it's bounded by this
complex looking
uh term uh the most salient
feature i want to point out though is it
is one over square root
n where n we recall is the size of your
training set
okay so this pack guarantee essentially
says
your estimation error is not too large
it is upper bounded by one over square
root n
that means if you have big data if n is
large
then your estimation error really is
very
close to zero so that's one
main message the other message is the
hypothesis space
size of capital h enters the picture
through a long term okay so we can
tolerate
exponential sized hypothesis space
but cannot tolerate infinite hypothesis
okay so that's that now um
one one thing i want to point out is
this is
a general pack guarantee for uh agnostic
case meaning that
uh our hypothesis family may not contain
the true
uh h star it turns out if
you are in a luckier realizable case
you can sharpen this to one over n
that's
much faster than one over square root n
so in the realizable case
estimation area is even more favorable
okay
but as we mentioned before pac learning
guarantee really doesn't control
anything about
approximation error or base error so in
other words
at the end of day your r of h hat
could still be quite large could be you
know
50 error or something like that and
you would have no control over that all
you have guaranteed
is your estimation area is close to zero
but
it doesn't mean you get a good
classifier in any sense
all right so um let's see uh
i think i'm going to skip like uh
how we get to that uh interesting
conclusion but
it's really an application of
concentration of measures
uh making sure that because all those
training set
is just the monte carlo estimate of the
true risk
that's the thing you utilize with the
slight complication that
you are using that training set both to
do monte carlo estimate
and to pick your erm uh
classifier or erm hypothesis that
complicates things
so we have to apply union bound to get
uniform convergence
okay so but that's that that's where
that size of uh capital h
comes into picture i'm happy to
uh discuss this offline or do you think
i guess it's okay we so i think we can
go on okay
all right so um now
uh recall that the the pac-man i gave
you
only applies to uh finite hypothesis
but even in my simple example earlier my
hypothesis space is already this
infinite threshold function
right so intuitively
even though this is an infinite
hypothesis space
it's really not that complicated and we
should be able to
learn in a sense of uh guaranteeing
estimation error
and the problem really is we use the
union bound on the previous
page which is too weak for our situation
so um this
vc dimension is essentially the crown
jewel
of classic learning theory it
precisely characterizes which hypothesis
space are learnable and which are not
the conclusion is if you have a finite
vc dimension
you are learnable in the sense that your
estimation error is bounded
okay so what is vc dimension of a
hypothesis family
uh it's a mouthful so let me read this
it's the size t
of the largest set this is the set of
input items x i 1 to x i t
if you can find you know essentially t
different input items such that
they can be assigned all possible
combination of labels by your hypothesis
space this is known as shattering
then that t is the bc dimension you look
for
one such largest set and the size of the
set is the vc dimension so let's look at
an example
take our hypothesis space of you know
all threshold functions
let's try t equals one t equals one
is trivial you can pick any item in
particular the first item x equals one
and say oh yeah i have all two possible
labelings
uh it's going to be x equals one is
going to be labeled
as zero by my second hypothesis h2
it's going to be labeled as one by the
first hypothesis okay
so i can find a set of size 1
that is shattered what about t equals 2
right so let's
try x equals 1 x equals 2
as the two items let's see if we can
find hypotheses
that will shatter them so it's clear
that you know
i can get both zero and zero labeling on
those two items
by just any threshold function with a
large threshold
i can get 0 1 by h2 i can get
1 1 by h1 except that i couldn't
find the hypothesis in my capital h that
can label
x 1 as 1 but x 2 as
0 because my threshold is in the going
up
direction and in fact you can easily
prove that
it's not a problem with your choice of x
1 x
2 no pairs can have
uh can have this kind of labeling
okay so we failed and that means the
largest
p that can be shattered is just one and
so our vc dimension in this case is one
okay so this is a very interesting
combinatorial concept and it turns out
with this we can sharpen our
pack guarantee the the one on top is
what we saw previously
but stated slightly differently that's
what finite h
now the the new version says well you
only need
finite vc dimension for your hypothesis
space
if it's finite you can replace that log
h term with the vc dimension term
okay and you still get this uh
dependency
of one over square root n on the
trending set size
okay so because the vc dimension is
fixed it's a constant right
again we see that if you have more and
more training data
your your erm learned
classifier h hat will have good
uh estimation error
okay so that's all there is uh that's
all
what pac learning is saying
okay so we're actually down with you
know it's a very quick tour of
what passive learning uh
has to offer at a very high level
uh the story is we get our training set
as id from drawing from this
underlying joint distribution pxy
and it is the environment who's joined
that dataset for us
so the learner has no influence how on
how that data is collected
it's just given that s for this reason
this is
known as passive learning because you
know the learner is passively
given us and asked to learn from it
it's not actively acquiring data and
that's going to give you contrast with
immediately with uh what we will do
pretty much for the rest of the talk
the environment you can also think of it
as not being particularly helpful
in the sense that it's kind of neutral
it
just has this joint distribution which
could even be noisy
and it's just sample id items from it
right so it's not super helpful
what we know is it depends on
the learner's hypothesis space h or in
particular the vc dimension of that
capital h when the vc dimension is
finite
there is an estimation error bound on
the order of one over square root n
that's all
there's no control over approximation
and base error
and i put a footnote here right so this
is the classic
picture about like 10 years ago
and with deep learning
people start to realize that to analyze
deep learning models you actually
require some additional theory
in particular because um we are not
just doing erm with deep nets
we're actually using specific algorithms
right so like like sgd
that you arrive at a particular answer
okay
that algorithm comes into the picture
because
it implicitly constrains uh
your capital h family you're not able to
reach everything in there
so that brings up some interesting
and uh you know open questions on how
you model that
so it's an active research area but
that's
my uh first part we will move on to
active learning but let's see if there
are any questions or
comments so if there are any questions
please put them in the chat or the q a
or
for panelists please unmute yourself and
ask
any questions
i think we can move ahead with the next
uh part of the talk
all right so let's move on to active
learning
uh as many of you know this is a place
where the learner
starts to literally play a more active
role
um just for simplicity we will assume
there's no base error that just means
you know the
nature doesn't have label noise okay if
you query x it's always going to give
you
h star access the answer okay and
we will assume there is no approximation
error that the true concept
is in your the learner's hypothesis
space
both can be relaxed but we will do that
for simplicity
okay so here is the active learning
protocol
there is going to be you know this
capital h again
the learner possess that
the environment has some age star okay
in that family okay that's the true
concept to be learned
now um what's different is first of all
learning is non-sequential so we have a
notion of t
that goes from one to up to you know
whenever you want to stop
uh second uh the uh the word is no
longer generating data
sampled from the underlying p rather in
step two
at time t the learner is going to
look at the whole interaction history so
far
including what it has done before what
answers it received from the world
and it decides what query xt
to perform so that's just a fancy name
to say you know
the learner gets to pick an itemxt in
the input space
and pose it as a question to the
environment
and in step three the environment is
required
to answer truthfully with the correct
label for that xt
so that forms a pair xt yt that label is
given back to the learner
so from that xtyt pair the learner is
going to
update its estimate of the model now
because things are sequential
i'm using h hat but with a subscript t
as a as a way to denote that
the learner could change its mind as it
sees more
examples
um there are two flavors of querying
um one is the learner has
the power to just like we call it
synthesizer just pick
any x in the capital x space
okay this is very similar to the
membership
query that's well known uh in the in the
query
learning by query type of work it's a
special case
there uh here you can generalize this to
arbitrary label space
okay so that's one type of
query but sometimes in in practice
people
don't like it because if you think of a
feature representation like our usual
feature space
x it's actually fairly hard to for the
learner to to construct or synthesize a
little x that will make sense to the
oracle
which usually are human experts like you
know
in the case of images it's hard if your
image is represented in the pixel
feature space it's hard for the learner
to guarantee that
an x actually makes visual sense to a
human
uh oracle so for that reason
uh there's a different way to generate
this query
and this assumes that the environment
still has
a marginal distribution on x remember
the py given x part is
fixed it's clear but px is
a distribution that the environment
possesses for example distribution
over natural images and here in step two
there is an inner loop
the learner basically keeps drawing from
that
uh marginal distribution like just give
me an honorable image give me another
unlimited image
until it is happy with the exit
received it decides to use that x
as x t okay this
interaction assumes uh drawing from the
unlabeled distribution
incurs no cost so the only cost that we
are concerned here is how many labels we
ask in step three okay so only both
queries uh joining things does not incur
anything
okay uh jerry there's a question in the
chat about
what's an example of an oracle right so
i guess yeah an article
literally uh in the in the usual machine
learning sense an article
literally is a human annotator and this
is the case for say
image classification right so you have
uh you have
you you suddenly need to create a data
classifier for cats versus stocks
but assuming you don't have any training
set so what you might be doing is you
do number two you pick a natural image
xt a photo
of something you give it to a human
annotator
like transsourcer right so you give it
to that annotator and say hey
please tell me the correct label for
this photo that's going to be yt
and we assume the human annotator
in their mind they have that h star so
they are able to
perform that labeling for you they can
evaluate h star x t
for you and they will give you back yt
so that's the
usual assumption
all right so let's let's look at a
stylized example not
cancer versus dogs i wish i could do
that but this is much simpler
and it's very similar to our earlier
example except that i made
x continuous and it's bounded between
zero one so our
input space is
just the interval between zero and one
real numbers
let's say p x is uniform over that okay
so
y is again binary right now um
i'm going to define uh threshold
functions it's against
step up threshold function so left is
going to be
zero class right one class
uh it's defined by a threshold little a
that little a is between zero and one
okay so that's our little h a
my hypothesis space is going to be all
these step up
threshold functions with you know a uh
in 0 1 right so it's an infinite
collection of those
we assume that there is a true h star
which is a true threshold function
with the special threshold a star
somewhere we don't know okay
and our job is to find uh that h
star or you know have an estimate of h
hat t that's close to h star
now if you think about our active
learning protocol you immediately
see that aha this is nothing but binary
search
or rather i could do binary search on
this problem right so i'm going to
as an active learner knowing that the
space is 0 1 i'm going to
first query x1 equals half
and the world has to the article has to
give me the correct
label depending on the which side a star
is
okay knowing the true label
what it helps me is it really helps me
throw away half of my hypothesis space
it's either the left half between zero
and half is
the threshold cannot be there or the
other half my threshold
cannot be there okay so
that's the first query right so knowing
that i know the answer i
i cut off half of my um hypothesis space
next query is going to be the midpoint
point
of the surviving uh half okay
and again we i can cut off a half of
that so one fourth of the original space
and
so on so forth right so if your a-star
is like a generic
real number um you don't expect your
binary search to ever
hit it exactly however what you can
guarantee
is your threshold uh well rather the
surviving hypothesis space
this is kind of cut down
by half after each query okay
that's what you can guarantee and if you
were to stop
at any moment and to say hey what did
you learn you could as a learner
arbitrarily pick
a hypothesis a threshold from the
surviving interval
okay so let's look at that right as we
were saying
after n active queries the interval of
course by binary search
uh has length one over two to the ends
and um
with no good reason to decide which one
of the threshold within the interval is
the best
let's assume the learner is going to you
know pick an arbitrary
h hat t now what's the risk
um because our px is uniform it's not
hard to show that
the true risk of what you learned at
this stage
is upper bounded oh i should sorry um
this should be h
hat n is upper bounded by one over two
to the ends
okay so
it's small it's actually exponentially
decreasing
right so the way you compare it
against the the original thing uh
that we said in passive learning there
we bonded
uh estimation error at the rate of 1
over n that that's because it's a
realizable case
and because of our assumptions there's
no base error there's no approximation
error so this is literally the risk
so in the passive learning case you can
get a rate of uh one over n
and that's also intuitive the way you
think of it
is like with a uniform px distribution
if you were to draw
an item's id they are roughly speaking
uh you know on the regular grid between
zero and one with those
n items therefore the uh the uncertainty
interval the surviving interval
is going to be of size one over n okay
so that's a much wider interval
than what you would get with active
learning here
jerry there's a clarification question
uh why is the exponential bound only an
upper bound
because you could get lucky right you
could uh
oh do you mean why it's not a lower
bound you could get lucky like you just
guessed an edge hat t
that happens to hit the thresh at the
truth threshold
is that uh i don't know if this answers
the question
um let's see yes the question
says it does thanks okay thanks
all right so now we see a huge
improvement right it's like okay
with active learning you can learn a lot
faster
however this only applies to the very
special case of you know this 1d
threshold over the interval and we are
using binary search we know how to do
that
the question is can you generalize this
okay generalize this to arbitrary
hypothesis space not just intervals
to do that we need to introduce two
concepts one is the notion of
version space i have already saying that
being saying that for a while
a version space v is simply
a subset of my hypothesis space that
agrees with all data so far so
in other words that's the surviving
interval of thresholds
okay in general though for non-threshold
problem you can still define
the version space it's any hypothesis
that
survived all the data uh
the labeled data that you have seen so
far okay so that's the version space
on top of that version space there is
the notion of a disagreement
region induced by a version space
so a version space is a subset of
hypothesis
a subset of classifiers but a
disagreement region
is a subset of the input space
it's the part of the input where your
version space
is still disagreeing okay so in other
words
you have a version space if it's very
small like a small interval
uh many part of the x your version space
would
completely agree upon okay because you
know they're
they every classifier in your version
space
would classify that point as a negative
point
while um disagreement region is
as we said here the part of x
space where there exists two hypotheses
in your version space that disagree
on how it should classify that
okay all right so with this
i'm going to introduce a very simple
algorithm that generalizes
uh active learning to uh to at least the
nice case
uh nice case being hypothesis space
again is
finite and our true target h star
is in the hypothesis space it's
realizable okay
so what do we do by this this is a
algorithm that
maintains a version space right so it's
just like what we
saw earlier it maintains the the
interval of possible thresholds
you initialize that version space v by
the whole hypothesis space
now um step two is kind of interesting
you
look if your current inversion space
induces a disagreement region right so
part of the x space
in the beginning very likely it's the
whole x space
and you you see what what
marginal probability the world puts on
that disagreement region
is it bigger than epsilon or not in the
beginning it's going to be yes
so you enter the loop what are you doing
there right
you um you keep
drawing x from the underlying px so this
is easy this is the unlabeled query that
we already saw
you can ask the world hey google me
another photo google me another photo
something like that without knowing the
true label
okay but what you do is you want to
accumulate
k such points that are in the
disagreement region
of your current version space that you
can check as a learner you maintain your
version space so you can
you know make sure you have k points
that's in there
what is implicit here is you also reject
potentially a very large number of x
points
that your current version space agrees
on and this is
actually the power of active learning
okay you are focusing your
labeled effort on points that uh are
still
disagreed upon okay so that's that's
where the hidden power
is so once you have k points
you're going to simply ask the oracle to
label
all these k points all at once okay
so you get a mini batch of k labeled
trending items then you update your
version spacing step five
so that's also very simple you just cut
off
any uh hypothesis that disagrees with
this new batch of points so you maintain
you know points that uh
are perfectly in agreement so far so
this reduces your resize
right so you keep doing that okay
that's the algorithm it's very simple
[Music]
now technically what does it
do the way you can think of this
is if you have the right amount of
k if you set k correctly then after
querying
these k disagreeing points you're going
to reduce your version space
sufficiently
and sufficiently is in in a special
sense it's in the
particular sense of radius but uh we
don't have to go into that the intuition
is
you reduce your version space guaranteed
by
a constant fraction in this case half
and because of that this becomes
essentially a generalization of binary
search
okay and then we have a somewhat
scary scary-looking theorem the theorem
says if you set k
to be this quantity which is two times a
mysterious quantity called
theta we'll come back to that times log
hypothesis over delta
log log one over epsilon right so this
is
uh the way best way to think of it is
like ah it's like
kind of a theta ish quantity okay so big
o theta ish
ignoring log factors then
you're going to uh terminate and uh you
will have
a guaranteed learned model that
is epsilon good to risk nice
the total number of labeled queries you
have to do
in step three if you add up all these
thresholds
it's kind of it's kind of like this big
o
term in there right so let me break it
down into you know
really three parts the first first part
is uh
log one over epsilon where epsilon here
is your desired
accuracy okay log one or wraps along is
always good
okay so um you basically
if you equate um n the number of total
queries to this
log of one of epsilon you see that the
risk
is uh decreasing exponentially it's one
over e to the n
right so bigger of that so it's it's
exponential it's better than
uh passive learning the second term
is this theta in there so okay that that
says you know theta better be
a smallish quantity okay it should not
be infinity
at least okay then the third term is
some log log
log terms let's ignore that for now okay
so what we have seen here is um
yeah this seems to be working except
that we don't know what that theta is
and
we want that theta to be small jerry
there's a
question on the q a yeah the question is
can the cal algorithm be framed as
greedily maximizing
information gain aha
let's see uh
[Music]
no not directly uh simply because
this is uh well um
uh i i okay it's a longer discussion but
i i don't think
it is directly maximizing information
gain
because it really is uh very simple
right so the
you pick a query simply because at least
two surviving hypotheses disagree on its
uh classification
okay so we're not really trying to work
too hard
we're not trying to say this maximizes
some notion of
either uncertainty or information gain
okay we're still relying on
px and it's actually px you know you you
do kind of rejection sampling right
so this is a much more relaxed version
than uh the kind of active learning
information gain type of criteria
and what's amazing is we can still give
theoretical guarantees
i also thought raised hand from uh
noreen i think
is there a question
okay and then a question for rasborik in
the chat for what classes of h
is uh dis of v computable
ah uh excellent question
so uh
for for the classes that's of interest
to you i assume it's hard to compute
okay so this v is already hard
and uh there is something else that i'm
getting to
so sorry not to answer your question
directly we only know how to compute
this
this well this fee is easy to define but
what family is computationally
uh you know cheap to compute
uh the active learning community do not
pay enough attention to that question
sorry um yeah sure
but let me also point out now let's come
back to this science the satay is going
to be a bigger problem
okay so what is this theta sata is
defined in a strange way okay this is
known as
disagreement coefficient um so let me
parse the top
equation for you a little bit uh what we
do here is
imagine we have uh imagine that the
first the hypothesis space we have h
star in our hypothesis space now imagine
you grow a ball
around it with some radius r so what is
the
distance measured here it is going to be
the disagreement like h x not
equal h prime x the
loss function right the zero one lost
that uh
under p x the true environment
margin okay so it's their disagreement
probability
that's your uh distance between
hypothesis
so and in any ways you start from each
star in the center
grow a ball with radius r so that's
going to circle
some number of hypotheses in your
hypothesis space
now you say hey on what part of x space
do this ball disagree on so you look at
the disagreement
region of that and then finally you look
at the probability of
that disagreement region it's like hey
it's the large part of your input space
being disagreed on or not
right so that's the question here now as
we should expect
if i start r from zero or very near zero
and i
increase r my ball gets bigger i have
more hypothesis in this ball so they
tend to disagree more
and the probability of disagreement
region should grow right so
let's look at the rate of that growth
compared
against r the radius okay and i take
supremum so
anywhere as i grow this ball what's the
largest
rate of growth along the way that is the
quantity known as
theta and it's known as disagreement
coefficient
okay so this may all sound very abstract
let's look at a couple of examples
so for 1d threshold functions
that we have already seen
this ball is actually kind of easy to
compute
uh you can show it's uh it's simply the
interval
around the true threshold with uh you
know plus minus r
okay and for this reason
the probability of the disagreement
region is simply 2r
and therefore theta is just 2 okay
anywhere okay
so this is a case where we have a small
disagreement coefficient
for one dimensional threshold functions
and that's why my earlier binary search
is
very successful literally it's like it's
partly explained
by having a small theta here and what i
want to contrast
is the second example where my
hypothesis space
is no longer a threshold function but
rather an interval function still in one
d
so you can imagine this is just in 1d
but
the target is defined by some a star b
star
interval such that within the interval
everything is classified as say positive
and outside the interval is classified
as negative right
okay so for this hypothesis class
you might say well what's the difference
it's like one threshold versus two
thresholds
but it has a dramatic effect on the
disagreement disagreement coefficient
the expression is a little bit ugly to
read but just focus on the
inner 1 over max b star minus a star
epsilon term recall epsilon is the
desired
precision and b star minus a star is
actually the
the interval length for your target
concept that
you know it classifies things as
positive okay
so the difficulty comes when your target
concept
is just a blip it has a very small b
star minus a star
okay so it you know it's almost
everywhere negative except for a tiny
interval
where b star minus a star is um
is uh is positive it is you know
sorry that difference is small
in particular if that
interval length is on the order of
your desired epsilon then this is simply
the first
term inside the the max is
just one over epsilon okay that can be
quite large
okay that can be quite large and recall
this theta
let me go back my slide right this theta
comes into
the the the number of queries you know
as is as a as a linear term
okay so what does it say uh
why is one-dimensional interval in
trouble here
this is literally an example of what's
known as a warm start problem
if you have that target concept with
just a blip of positive island
without knowing where that little
interval is
the active learner actually has no idea
right it doesn't know where the positive
region is
so what can it do well it cannot do
anything
it can only sort of literally do a
random
you know randomly query in the beginning
until it happened to hit that little
island
okay but that's very expensive that's
already
uh requiring one over epsilon number of
items okay so this is known as the warm
start problem
once the active learner happens to hit
a point inside the target interval
then everything becomes nice because it
has one positive item inside it already
presumably have some
negative outside it can do two separate
binary searches
for the left and right interval
okay so after that stage it's fine but
to to get a point inside to get the
first positive point is the trouble spot
okay and that's reflected here in the
disagreement coefficient being large
okay finally i just want to point out
for a very studied
very well studied family of problems
being you know
our favorite high dimensional heifer
plans
they are very much like thresholds so
you can show on the
mild conditions the coefficient
the disagreement coefficient is order
one okay so they are small
all right and uh let me let me wrap up
this part
uh so the difference here in active
learning is the learner decides what
data point to collect xt right the
environment
says what label it is but the learner
decides where to ask the query
because of that um you can design
general active learning algorithms that
uh under favorable
conditions of that coefficient
disagreement coefficient
which is a property of your hypothesis
space
on the favorite conditions you get
exponential error bound which is nice
okay
ah great so um
let me let me contrast something uh
which i i know this is uh of great
interest
uh in the synthesis community uh
what if active learning use
something other than membership query
remember what we did previously is
essentially a membership query xt is a
membership
query but you could imagine the learner
just
asks for equivalence query so the
learner at some iteration just says hey
oracle
i have this whole hypothesis little h
hat t minus one
could you please take a look at it and
see if i got it or not
okay so the interaction is different the
learner asks
the learner exposes its whole hypothesis
little h hat t minus 1 at that moment
to the oracle the article either says
yes
your little h hat t minus 1 happens to
be h star
or no in that case the oracle is going
to give you a counter example
this counter example takes the form of
some item x t in the disagreement region
between h
star and your h hat t minus one
as well as its correct label y t
okay so that's the that's the uh the
equivalence
query and the based on that feedback
the learner estimates um updates its
estimate
now what i want to make a comment for is
like this
is actually not very well studied in
machine learning
because for the type of problems people
typically care about
like training a deep net uh to classify
cats and dogs
uh it's actually fairly hard to do
equivalence query that would be that
would essentially amounts to you know
the
learner gives the whole current network
weights
to some oracle and say hey do you think
this is the correct
network uh that's pretty hard
but i want to point out one thing
assuming we can do equivalence query
in the classic analysis of equivalence
queries
the counter example xt
is assumed to be adversarial meaning
that
the oracle can pick an arbitrary xt
in the disagreement region
okay it doesn't have to pick a helpful
one
okay so for that reason uh all the
analysis
literally assumes worst case it assumes
xt is the least helpful
uh within the disagreement region
okay but there's a difference
right so if you assume you can get a
more helpful
article in choosing the country example
for you
you can learn things much much faster so
let's again take a look at our
original example this goes back to the
discrete
threshold linear threshold function and
this time
i'm going to say the true threshold is
at age
2021 okay so you have a whole bunch of
zeros the 20
21st
x item will get positive label and so on
so forth
okay now let's say we do equivalence
queries
right uh you can imagine uh uh
the least helpful article with an
interaction could go like this
where the learner says hey i guess
uh i tried to be you know h1 my put
threshold at first place
is this the correct hypothesis and the
oracle says no
but i will give you a counter example uh
look at x
equals one i would classify it as zero
you you said it's one i'm going to say
it's zero right
now nothing prevents the learner from
saying oh well then i should guess h hat
equals
what we call h2 where you know
you put zero in the first place and one
afterwards
the oracle will say well no that's not
what i have in mind look
at location x equals two i classified it
as zero
and so on so forth right so it's going
to go on
like this for a while and this is
essentially what's assumed
in equivalence queries uh the
there's uh there's no assumption on the
uh
on the contrary example so we should
assume worst case
while um in the most helpful case
if you have an article that really is
there to help you
when you ask well yes uh i have this um
h hat being you know little h1 is this
right
the answer could be no um look my
contrary example is
x at 2020 that one i classified as
zero now by this the learner should
immediately
exclude everything every little age with
threshold before 2020
okay but it doesn't of course doesn't
prevent uh the learner
to do something crazy in the next step
like oh how about this uh
new age that puts a threshold at a
really large number
and the oracle would still say no right
but this time
it will be helpful and given the country
example at 2021
and say i i give you a label one there
so with just
two iterations of uh interaction
we should have a learner that precisely
learned
h star in this case
and this is an example exact way for me
to discuss
something we call machine teaching
jerry i i think uh
this may be a good point to take a few
minute break
so uh why don't we take a four minute
break
and then resume at uh uh 55 past the
hour
so 955 pacific um
in the meantime uh there is a question
on the chat from rasborik and there may
be other questions as well so we could
take those
okay for those people hang on so uh so
raj's
question is related to the warm start
problem
so he so he writes regarding the warm
start problem
could you define a new kind of label
slash query to the oracle
for example is the target interval
inside some guest interval
ah maybe to
put a broader perspective you know the
the learner is
essentially using uh
guiding the surge right by the knowledge
of age
so in some sense that algorithm is very
specific to h
yet the protocol for asking the query
to the oracle is fixed in general right
so one would want to maybe
change that query to the oracle as well
together with h
i i think that's an excellent uh point
uh it is not how it is done in the as
you know
in the classic active learning simply
because
uh there is a fixed notion that you know
a query can only be about membership
query
that's the machine learning mental uh
mentality there right
but i i suspect what you're suggesting
is kind of similar to uh
uh equivalence query yes i can see that
right an over approximation of such
right yeah
you could say you know uh i give you a
as a learner i give you a
bigger interval we're actually for for
that matter any interval right but i can
query you intervals
and uh you just tell me if it's right or
just give me a
different uh an example country example
in the
disagreement region which corresponds to
in the classic literature this is the
symmetric difference between
uh the h star and uh the learner's
current hypothesis
yeah i think yeah if you do that uh
you should be able to learn much better
yeah and i think in the in the
literature i think
that there is some work on in the
classic query based learning literature
there's some work on subset queries and
superset queries
i think that's that's what this
particular one belongs to
oh yeah yeah yeah true
okay um we still have two minutes before
the resumption points so uh there are no
other questions we can take a true break
okay
so jerry i i think given that we have
just about 35 minutes left uh you may
not be able to
finish all of the topics in the tutorial
um so uh i i do think machine teaching
is is super relevant and then
you might have to pick from the
remaining ones
based on the time available let's let's
do that uh i will adapt
yeah thanks
uh it's a bit of a pretty i mean if you
if you do have the bandwidth later it
would be nice if you can record
the the remainder of the tutorial and
we'll make it available to the attendees
that's a good suggestion yeah i mean
there's always like too many good
materials to talk about
and i also don't know which one of them
is directly of interest and which ones
may stimulate some you know uh not
developed yet
uh interactions between the communities
that's why i was trying to cram a lot of
things in there
yeah i do think machine teaching is is
really really really relevant so
um we're now at 56 past the hour so
let's
get started again all right
okay so um so so let's talk about
teaching right so this is a very
uh different notion uh than machine
learning uh
the mentality is completely different
we're no longer
in the business of learning a model from
data generated by the world
instead uh we are in the world of there
is a teacher
and the teacher already has a target
model maybe it's a well-trained network
maybe the teacher just
knows things so the teacher has a model
like h
star and uh um
maybe the teacher knows something about
the learner
so this could be uh you know the
learner's actual algorithm
uh or some guarantees that the learner
has
in that sense the question is
well can the teacher somehow give each
star to the learner
now except that you're not allowed to
directly give
each start to the learner you
for example for when the learner is
human kids you cannot just burn a model
edge starting their brain
okay so that is not allowed what you can
do
is you can produce data
in the form of again here we have a
labeled training set
as but now i'm going to call it teaching
set
maybe it has n items all we say is these
items are from you know the correct xy
space
but we no longer have any pxy notion we
we're not saying this as has to be
already sampled from something
the teacher has the power to construct
them okay
now the learner is a standard learner
okay
so it receives this trend uh teaching
set
and it's going to proceed as if it's a
standard training set
it's going to select a model or learn a
model literally chat
from its hypothesis space okay now the
teacher's goal here
is to number one make the learner learn
so it will make sure that each hat is h
star
okay but at the same time the teacher
wants to minimize the size of the
teaching set
okay so that's the teaching set let's
look at
some examples
you know the the issue here is
let's take the learner to be the
consistent or erm type of learner that
actually literally means the learner
maintains a version space
that is produced by any teaching set s
so
if you give the learner an s the learner
is going to
remove all um you know high empirical
risk
hypothesis and uh there's a this
equivalent argument set
right so that's the version space and
the learner can pick
any one h hat from that version space
now what we want to say is let's
define s more precisely right what is a
teaching set
s is called a teaching set for
the target concept little h star
but with respect to the student's
hypothesis space capital h
if by using s the teacher can
eliminate all hypotheses in the
student's mind
except for a little h star okay so
that's the requirement
um now of course let's look at
the example down there so here i have
again our
threshold functions uh and let's say the
teacher says okay i want to teach you
age 2021 right now
the training set as that has two items
2020 label 0 2021 label 1
with respect to the hypothesis class is
going to be a teaching set because it
excludes all other hypotheses from
capital
h but you can imagine just you can add
any consistent data items to us
that's still going to be a teaching set
okay so that's the concept now we define
teaching
dimension for
my concept little h star with respect to
capital h as simply the size of the
smallest
teaching set as so
that's the second to bottom line on the
screen
what is interesting here is if you think
about that
if your h star is h 20 21
you need two items in your teaching set
and in fact that is true
for any threshold uh that's bigger than
two
okay but for little h1 which is like
all all ones right if that is your
target
you only need one item
and because you can show x1 is labeled
as one
no other hypothesis can label x y as one
okay so you already exclude everything
else
okay so we can see that you know there
can be
variance or the differences
in what's the teaching set size
and we will finally define teaching
dimension of the whole hypothesis with
without regarding to which one is your
target
h star that just has a maximum
over all possible target little h stars
okay so in our case for our
threshold hypothesis class the teaching
dimension will be two
okay so here's a very uh
concrete example again what you're
seeing here is
uh the columns are items
now this is a finite domain it's not our
infinite domain so let's imagine we have
n distinct items the rows are different
hypotheses
in the hypothesis space the structure
here is very simple
you have basically a one hot
concept family it's one for
one of the items zero everywhere else
except
for h0 which is all zeros
okay so let's now think of you know what
is the teaching dimension for this
family
to teach little h1
is easy as a teacher i only need to show
uh
item x1 together with a positive label
label one
okay because that's the only h1 is the
only hypothesis that
labels x y as one okay so i
only need one item to teach sen
is true for little h2 i only need to say
look
x2 is one and then similarly up to
n right so all these just need one item
however in order to teach h0
it's actually not trivial because
if i say hey x y is zero uh that
only excludes little h1 it still has all
other hypothesis surviving
okay so i also need to say x2 is also
one uh also
it's also zero okay but that doesn't
help
much right because you still have h3 to
hn surviving
so at the end of end of day in order to
teach little h0
as a teacher you literally need to
enumerate all n
items and say all of these are zeros
okay so that's why the teaching
dimension for this
sim like simple looking hypothesis class
is actually n the number of items that's
much much larger than you would expect
and in fact
for people who are familiar with bc
dimension the vc dimension for this
sand class is just one because you
cannot find two same issue you cannot
find
two x points that are labeled as you
know both one zero and zero
one we don't have that
so it cannot be shattered by uh two
points cannot be shattered that's why
this is one
so looking at another example here where
uh it's a very similar structure we no
longer have that all zero hypothesis
instead what we have is we have a whole
bunch of hypotheses
uh and a whole bunch of input items uh
in the input space uh the structure is
as follows
let's start from the right hand side
after the dashed line
what there what what's there is
essentially a truth table for
k bits okay so you have two to the k
rows okay um but
on the left hand side what you have is
an indicator
so it's just like uh the the left hand
side is actually also true to the case
long and uh that is an indicator
okay so what we did is we basically did
a surgery we
concatenate an indicator on the left
with a
you know a full truth table on the right
okay the point is to show that
the teaching dimension for such a
hypothesis class is
very simple it's just one why because
you can use the left hand side
indicator you can just say you know look
x y
is one then you uniquely index h one
right
and similarly for all two to the case
hypothesis you can
do that the point we want to illustrate
here is
the difference between this and vc
dimension
because we put a truth table inside here
these hypotheses they can shatter k
points
precisely those are the k points on the
right hand side
the k columns on the right hand side
okay
so the vc dimension will be k
okay but the the teaching dimension is
much much smaller
okay so these are just two interesting
examples to illustrate that teaching is
really you know it's a different beast
compared to
uh learning some of the intuitions we
develop some of the theorems we develop
for uh learning no longer applies to
characterizing how large is your
necessary teaching set
in fact the precise relation between
uh the minimum teaching set size
teaching dimension
versus uh uh you know the size required
for learning that's characterized by vc
that is still a major open question
another way to think of machine teaching
is to say well this is nothing but a
coding problem
as a teacher i want to convey a message
to the student
and the message is simply each star my
target concept
except that the communication channel is
restricted
i can only use the language of labeled
training sets
okay or teaching sets so that's the
language is
going to be some notion of s labeled
item pairs
and also the decoder in the student is
also very special it is a learning
algorithm
okay so given that a conceptual way to
find
the minimum teaching set is simply to
solve posit as an optimization problem
right we minimize
over training set size over all training
sets we minimize the training set size
subject to this h hat s is
just the shorthand that the student
takes as
produces an h hat subject to that must
be h star
okay now uh this is just a conceptual
uh way to write it it's actually very
hard to solve for several reasons one is
it's a
it's a combinatorial search problem in
the space of training sets
yes but also that h-hat
s unit constraint itself may very well
be an optimization problem because
that's the machine learning problem the
the student is taking us and producing a
chat right so
there's a nested lower level
optimization so that makes the whole
problem a bi-level optimization problem
so it's not very easy to solve
you could relax this type of problem uh
by
you know just for example um
relax the cardinality of s by some more
general
effort function and then relax the
equality by saying okay i only
want to do approximate teaching not
exact teaching maybe
and then you can uh relax that by
some notion of distance between what the
student learned as
h hat from s versus the true
h star okay but in general the
computation is still
difficult in this setting
i think there's a question yeah jerry
there's a question
uh in the q a from marcel does the
teaching dimension relate to the channel
capacity
um not that i know of
but i really want to know because uh
posing it as a coding problem that is an
angle that i
don't see the machine learning community
analyze the problem yet
so that's uh that's a very good question
okay so um here's a short summary
in the teaching setting it's all about
constructing the teacher constructing a
teaching set
which forces the learner to learn a
target each star
that's known beforehand right and one
relevant
statement here is if you can compute the
teaching dimension
for that h star with respect to the
model family capital h this really
lower balance all sampling based
learning so
any learning activity is lower bounded
by this meaning that
this is the least amount of training
data you would require
okay any true learning algorithm will
require more than that
okay another
sort of interesting thing to point out
is
if you contrast teaching dimension in
our simple 1d threshold case
with say passive learning which we know
to achieve epsilon error you need
one over epsilon samples in active
learning you need
log one or epsilon right so epsilon is
let's say 0.001
in the passive learning you need 1000
samples in active learning you need
10 samples because you're doing binary
search uh teaching would only require
two samples
regardless what precision you want okay
so that seems like uh you know that's
the type of lower bounding we're talking
about
but also keep in mind it is a different
really a different problem because uh
here the teacher knows h
star and just try to communicate this to
the student
so that's that and uh given that i have
only 20 minutes left i'm going to skip
online learning but i want to
give a quick overview of multi-arm
bandits and reinforcement learning
so let me actually start with uh matam
bandit
uh this is a very interesting setting
which um
it's best to think of it not as
you know say for classification but uh
it's some notion of you know reward uh
maximization
so the setting is the following there's
an environment which has k
distributions and those are known as k
arms the bandit is
really come from the the the gambling
machine in the casino
the bandit machine right so you have a
machine with k arms
and if you pull an arm you will get a
random reward that's where it starts
with
so there are k arms each is associated
with a reward distribution capital r
now we use it for reward capital r 1 to
r k
now this distribution can be
you know anything that's a reasonably
light
tail so it could be a bernoulli it could
be a gaussian distribution
for each of this uh rewards what's
important is their min
so let's assume the means are like mu 1
to mu k
okay and intuitively if you play
this game long enough you really should
just keep
interacting with the arm that has the
highest
mu okay then you get highest average
reward that's what you are aiming for
okay except that you as a learner you as
a banded learner you
don't know those distributions you don't
know those means
okay so you have to interact with
the machine to figure out right so the
interaction protocol is
uh things again go sequentially and at
iteration t the learner decides on an
action and the action is simply choosing
from those k arms which arm to pull
so let's call it a t that's step three
we're going to pull an arm
by pulling the arm the environment is
going to generate a reward according to
that arm's reward distribution so the
little rt is a random variable it's
sampled from the distribution
capital rt from that corresponding arm
okay
okay so that's it right uh very simple
interaction protocol
the question is what should the learner
do
to uh to get as much reward
as possible okay so that's the question
now uh just to make things concrete
let's say there are two
arms we're talking about k equals two
and
each arm is a bernoulli zero one right
so it's like each arm is essentially a
biased coin so you flip it you're
putting arm is flipping it
the arms are biased so you don't know
it's true probability
okay all right so
um let's say we first pull arm one a one
uh and i get a reward r1
equals one so put in the first arm get
one
pulling the second arm i get a zero
question at this point what should i do
the third pool should i pull arm one or
arm two
and we can generalize this a little bit
uh
i'm sorry what uh i think i have some
something that's uh keep beeping
let me turn that off
okay can people see things okay
yeah it looks good all right thanks
sorry about that
um so more generally right you might be
in the situation where you have
already put arm one ten times and out of
the ten
seven times it you get one three times
you get zero so you get the
empirical estimate of 0.7 you have
pulled arm two five times
uh with an empirical estimate of point
four
right what should you do for the next
pull for your sixteenth pole
are you going to do arm one or arm two
right so that's the decision we have to
make
and the intuition here is uh this is
intrinsically a trade-off
you don't know the arm distributions you
don't know their means so you need to
pull each one enough to get a reasonable
estimate of which arm truly has the
highest
mean but you don't want to overdo it if
you do it
too much then necessarily you are
wasting some of the posts on sub optimal
arms and you don't get as much
cumulative reward okay so it's all about
that
critical balance
um so there are actually two
distinct goals that one can study
the first one is more natural it's
called pure exploration
and this says you have t pools that you
can use capital t
and you can do whatever pose you want
the outcomes for those capital t pools
doesn't you you're not
charged against it okay so you can do
whatever you want but all you want to
make sure is
after those t pools um you have decided
which army is the best
and that's uh that's characterized here
you hope
that the decision you make after all
people's
a capital t plus one uh should be
the best arm or uh one of the best arms
and you want to maximize the probability
of
that happening now this is a
probabilistic statement simply because
along the way all the rewards you see
are random okay so those are random
variables
and that would affect your decision
right so uh so that's why it's a
it's a probability statement here
another goal here
which is distinct from uh best arm
identification which is also known as
pure exploration
is regret minimization okay and regret
minimization is
equivalent to just you know maximize the
cumulative
reward among the t trials okay so here
you have to be careful you don't want to
pull sub-optimal arms too much
right we define regret
which is um this mu star which is the
uh best arms reward average reward times
t
so that's in expectation if you just
keep pulling the best arm
what what would you get right minus your
cumulative reward
okay so there's a gap everything is in
expectation sense
we study this instead of cumulative
reward
simply because uh this quantity can be
bonded so in some ways this is very
similar to exploration
uh exploration error sorry
estimation error in supervised learning
and this is clearly an exploration
exploitation trade-off
because um as i was saying if you
explore
too much then you start to push up
optimal arms
excessively without you know truly
improving things
but if you don't explore too much you
you decide on pulling an
arm that looks good so far without
fully be certain about it that's called
exploitation
and you may be trapped in your own false
belief
and miss a truly better arm okay so
that's a very delicate
balance um the
one thing i want you like this is a very
long theorem but
one thing i want to
you know just emphasize here is there is
a very nice
way to think about problems of this
nature
which is to say you should explore
but you should explore with some con you
know some controlled fashion
so let's look at this algorithm called
the upper confidence bound or ucb
algorithm
it's a quite famous algorithm for
material bandit it's for the regret
setting
um so there are so what you do is as a
learner you keep pulling arms you
accumulate mu hats those
are nothing but just empirical estimates
right so maximum likelihood estimate
except that at any moment at the
iteration t
when you decide which arm to pull you
are taking the arg max of
not just the empirical estimate of each
arm mu hat i
you stick another term you add another
term to it that
takes the form of square root log t over
t i where t i is the number of times
the ice arm has been pulled so far up to
time little t okay
what does this do so let's imagine you
have not pulled arm
2 very much so t 2 would be very small
at this moment
if it's small that means the relative
size of the square
term will be large as opposed to if you
have put
arm two many times then the square term
will be small
this square root addition is known as
a exploration bonus it
tries to encourage you to explore
to pull arms that looks bad new height
is small
but you have not sufficiently explored
and you may ask
where does this where does this bonus
come from
well it comes from as we can see here
upper confidence bound
there's a the intuition is
this mu hat plus that additional term
you can think of it
as the confidence interval in which the
true mu
i lives in okay this is the upper half
in spawn there's a you know mu
minus that that's the lower bound that
together form the interval
um there's there are some technical
adjustments but roughly speaking that's
what it is
and what you're doing is you are simply
assuming because you have uncertainty in
arm mean estimate you're just being
super optimistic
you're just saying every arm at the
moment i'm going to assume it
it can be as large as the confidence
interval tells me
okay so that's what it is jerry a
clarification here yeah
so um mu hat i is that
the learner's estimate of the reward
distribution of rsi
yeah it's uh it's literally the maximum
likelihood estimate right so if you flip
a coin
sometimes it's end up seven hats it's
0.7 nothing
beyond that and then capital t sub 80
what is that ah right so uh
little a t is the arm the learner
decides to pull like arm
one or arm two right so let's say a
little 80 is two
it decides to pull arm number two uh
then
capital t sub 80 is capital t two
right that simply says whoa you you
increment the counter for
arm two you know you now put it one more
time that's all
i see good thank you okay yeah as you
can see this t
uh t80 increases therefore the bonus
term would decrease as
you know as this goes on right but again
if you
didn't pull an arm for a very long time
that kind of the bonus relative bonus
sticks out as being large relatively
okay so you can analyze this type of
algorithm and at the end of the day you
get a regret
bound of the following sort and what's
really important here
is the square root t term okay you can
ignore all the things k is the number of
arms t is the total number of iterations
total number of
interactions uh what we
want what we like about this is this is
a standard
no regret type of guarantee that's a bad
name what the
this literally means is regret is the
sum of over
all capital t's if you calculate per
time step
like you divide everything by capital t
that square root of t becomes one over
square
t and it becomes it approaches zero as t
increases right so
that's asymptotically you have no regret
okay
so that's the type of guarantee that we
would like
okay so this is a very interesting
algorithm it achieves a no regret
guarantee
by simply doing encourages exploration
but not too much
specifically by an upper confidence
bound
let me skip this and uh and talk about
uh oh wow okay so uh
quickly quickly uh
contextual bandit is one level up where
now suddenly we have a notion of state
okay and then
each state has k arms
and uh you know they may have their own
distinct
distribution okay so you pull this uh
so as the learner what happens is the
environment in step three
is going to draw a state for you and say
hey look that's your context
and for that context you decide which
arm is the best
so you essentially have you know
separate embedded problems one for each
state
okay this is
an intermediate setting the reason i
introduce this is
it really goes towards reinforcement
learning
it's almost reinforcement learning
except that
the next state is drawn in step three by
the environment
and as you can see it is drawn from a
fixed distribution it's not a
conditional distribution it does not
depend on st minus one okay so that's
important so you can think of
this setting as if it's a specialized
reinforcement learning setting and
the multi markov decision process where
the next
state is
is not a true sort of first order
transition but
there is a fixed new distribution
to draw the next state okay so no
transition essentially no no
meaning for transition okay
uh so that's that uh but let me
now jump to the real interesting thing
which is reinforcement learning
a little bit more definition but really
the only difference is
uh from content contextual bandit is now
you have a first order state transition
in particular
the uh the third item you
now if you are you were at state s you
perform some action a
your next state is going to be
determined by a conditional distribution
that
depends on s so you have uh you know
just one step of memory
it's the markovian property that's why
it's called markov decision process
okay other than that things are very
straightforward
you still have reward distribution but
for each state
for different actions you have different
rewards right so now we generalize arms
to actions but it's really the same
thing as you have k
actions there is an initial state
distribution so that
defines where the whole thing starts as
the first
state is drawn from nu but otherwise
it's following
the conditional distributions there is
also a discounting parameter
uh we will see that soon that's really
think of it for mathematical convenience
okay interaction protocol uh very
straightforward
uh as we were saying um learner
uh has some policy pi zero
and the policy is simply a mapping from
the current state to hey what action
should i perform
and this could be randomized so in
general a policy maps a state
to a distribution over actions
so that's the policy now in step two
environment
starts from sum s0 then for each time
step this learner in step 4
sees what state it is in using st
it looks up its policy pi and say oh i'm
going to have this distribution over
actions
and i'm going to draw my action 80 from
the distribution
now the environment is going to generate
a reward from
that uh uh st 80 combination
and furthermore the environment is going
to transit the learner to
st plus one according to the conditional
first order
um transition conditional probability
and with this additional you know uh
knowledge then the learner sees little
rt
and little s t plus one it will update
its policy
okay so then the whole thing goes like
that in iterations
was there a comment
um i don't see anything okay good
um then
what do we want we want
to find good policies that will increase
or maximize the value function so what
does this mean
this is literally the same as bandit but
you know with more
bells and whistles simply because now
you have to worry about a random
trajectory
so the value function defined for an
s is defined as you know you start the
interaction protocol
from s0 being that s you start from
there
and then you simply follow pi and the
whole
mdp interaction protocol you will
generate a random sequence of rewards
little r t that goes from zero to
infinity here's where the discounting
factor comes in
you are discounting each one by gamma to
the t power so gamma think of it as like
0.9
uh so what this does is it literally
puts more weight on immediate rewards
and
smaller weight on future rewards so that
things are
well defined but there's some evidence
like
people would discount future rewards so
that it's kind of like a hand-wavy
argument for why this is
justified to find
this way we can talk about optimum
policy identification that's one of two
goals of reinforcement learning
the pi star here in the
is simply the policy that will result
in the largest average
value here average is taken over where
you start
the whole trajectory that uh that's from
the new distribution
okay so that's a very well defined
concept we want to
sometimes we want to do that another
type of analysis is when we do again
regret minimization
so here we're simply saying okay if i
know the optimal policy and i
follow it for the whole trajectory i get
v pi star
as my value but as a learner i don't
know pi star so i'm
learning as we go i incur this sequence
of reward sequence little rt
that is usually inferior to the v pi
star
quantity how much different is it that's
going to be the regret
okay i'm going to skip oh i think we're
running out of time i'm going to skip a
bunch of things
i just want to show you yeah you can do
proper
analysis to guarantee reinforcement
learning actually works
and this is by the way a very hot
research topic
for the last two years
i just may have one minute or
yeah i think let's let's go till uh 35
past the hour
okay thanks so what i really want to say
is
that's the standard reinforcement
learning story uh
so far but what's interesting is you
because reinforcement learning is quite
rich there are multiple agents
you can start to introduce very
interesting interactions you can start
to introduce
like teachers and the teachers are you
know
helpful right so what might that look
like
it turns out there are two senses of
help for teacher
at least two senses in reinforcement
learning the first one
is known as imitation learning and the
story here
is you might have like a human expert
say a human
professional race car driver who is
who knows how to handle driving think of
driving as a reinforcement learning
problem
you see the image in front of you of the
street
cars etc and your action
space is let's say the steering angle uh
steering wheel angle
that's your action space right so that's
a reinforcement learning problem
and you might have human experts who are
really good at
this task now imitation learning says
well look at the expert
you can observe how experts drive
a race car okay so what you can
realistically see
is the s sequence meaning the
the scene in front of the car you can
capture it with a camera
you can capture the a sequence action
sequence the
sequence of steering wheel angles that
the
expert used to react to each scene
but you normally would not
see the reward given
by the world to the human driver
okay that's hidden to you you cannot see
that
so what you might have is a helpful
expert
who demonstrates a driving trajectory
in the form of only s a pairs but not
the r's so you're missing the r part
right
and uh can you still use it
to learn a good driving policy pie hat
that performs as good as the human
driver
the the thing is yes you can show tensor
but it requires
specialized learners and these are not
going to be standard reinforcement
learning algorithms so that's
point number one you design specialized
learner for that
and just to give you uh there are two uh
big families
under this heading of imitation learning
one is simply behavior cloning
and that simply says look at the state
action state action pair
that is nothing but a classification
problem
i can train a classifier so if i give if
i'm given a state
i predict how the human driver would
perform which action the human driver
would perform
so you just break it down into you know
a supervised learning problem
that's one type of method called
behavior cloning
the other type of method is called
inverse reinforcement learning and here
the learner tries to estimate the hidden
the latent
reward function okay so that's
helpful for teacher number one let me
just this is the last slide okay the
help for teacher number two
is a very different type of teacher
it helps a standard reinforcement
learner
okay so think of it as you know skill
the student is interacting with the
standard multi-markov decision process
environment and generating the usual
trajectory as
ar as prime trajectories however
imagine a new entity called a teacher
who can
insert herself in between the
environment
and the student and in particular what
the teacher can do
is it can modify the either the reward
or the state transition that the learner
experiences okay so for example the
teacher can you know add a little delta
to the environment generated reward and
this r
plus delta will then be given to the
student
okay now to the rl learner
it doesn't know it's there's a teacher
so it's just going to take the modified
experience and learn from it but
for the teachers but from the teacher's
perspective
the teacher knows what is an optimum
policy so the question here is
how can the teacher or can the teacher
even design
a sequence of say deltas for the reward
change
so that it helps the student learn the
optimal policy pi star
as quickly as possible okay
and that problem turns out to be it
certainly has a flavor of machine
teaching and
it turns out to solve that problem is a
high-level
rl or planning problem for the teacher
herself
this is another problem where
the teacher needs to plan ahead for the
set of deltas
without fully knowing what how the
student might react
and importantly the high-level state
representation
from the teacher's perspective would
include
learners in their internal model at that
moment so it's going to be an
enriched state space and it's a a much
bigger much more complex reinforcement
learning problem
um so that's kind of what i want to get
out
as a very high level uh pointer to you
know these are some things
happening in the machine learning
community and we know some
of them we know how to analyze some of
them
so hopefully this would encourage some
dialogue between our communities
thank you so much thank you jerry
thank you for a really excellent
tutorial um that
covered such a broad and deep topic in
less than two hours
uh we have a couple of questions here i
know we're over time but let's do this
radhu grossu and then anna lukina
hi jerry thank you very much for the
talk very nice
i just wanted to ask you about the first
the previous slide
on the teacher
yeah so so actually you you could use
supervised learning to
uh you know to just learn uh the actions
you know
uh what uh what the controller
the policy is supposed to do yeah so
your point is that
the teacher might not be optimal and
that's why you
i mean the expert might be not optimal
he's providing you the trajectories but
he might have not optimized the rewards
and then the idea is to
to find out how to optimize that that
that's one way to look at it right so uh
as you pointed out
one limitation in this kind of imitation
learning setting
yes if you just do behavior cloning
specifically
uh then it is limited by how good the
human expert is
right so the the human policy may not be
the optimum policy yet
yeah and so um if you just do human uh
behavior cloning you're you're
suddenly you know just try to mimic what
a human does which is sub-optimal policy
right like like when you're a driver you
if you just learn from the
from the teacher you know and uh then
you are not
never going to be better than the the
teacher but you you if you
learn on your own you might become
actually a formula one
and this is sometimes called to achieve
superhuman performance
yeah yeah excellent all right yeah
thank you very much anna did you have a
question
uh yes thanks i have a question about
active learning
yes so in the active learning setting is
there something
um is there some theory about modeling
the oracle itself the human supervisor
well the human expert such that the
machine approach could also
kind of predict the labels at some point
oh
okay um so these are actually two
separate questions let me try to address
them
in the standard uh assumption uh yes you
can
so what this is is um
basically the standard model is um well
i give you
like let's say i'm the active learner i
give you a query x and you're the human
expert right
what i assume of you is if you are
very good you should just give me h star
of x
like a deterministic label but if
uh i recruit say crowdsourcers and
they're not
super good right and they're distracted
they're watching tv or whatever while
doing my task
they will give me noisy labels and that
is modeled usually as a p
y given x such that
h star x should still be the sort of the
best
among the within the you know the
conditional class distributions
but you put probability mass on other
labels
right so it's it's a way to
model like noisy uh feedback
uh unfortunately just by having
in this kind of model directly doesn't
give me as the active learner
a way to predict that uh h star
like i can easily model an add a noise
model on top of what
the edge star is but i don't have enough
information
to assume what h star is if that makes
sense
so that's kind of the answer to your
second question in that
just by assuming the behavior of the
oracles
doesn't give me the truth
you can matter how bad they are but you
don't know what their true answer
is but based on this
uh noisy model i can maybe be skeptical
about the
labels of the ex oh yeah yeah yeah i
mean that's very important so in fact
um this is uh this is actually quite
important
for many problems you should assume
noisy label
and in doing so for example our binary
search would not work
because you are not supposed to cut off
half of your hypothesis phase right
based on one answer
so that's going to uh put like
yeah it's going to make active learning
weaker really because you need
a lot more queries just to be certain
and it turns out
if you have noise in labeled answers
sometimes you will not no longer be able
to achieve exponential speed up
i see thank you all right
uh i think with that uh let's
thank jerry again for really an
excellent tutorial
thank you and i i want to mention that
we are following up this tutorial
i think it really sets the stage for a
few sessions to come in this workshop so
we'll have
at least two probably more uh sessions
that talk about machine learning and
synthesis so i think jerry our tutorial
has
helped set the basic uh ground for
what's to come now
thank you great thank you all thank you
very much
thanks thanks everyone thank you see you
next week bye
you